la france va mieux mais les français
vont un peu moins bien c'est la
conclusion du dernier rapport de l'insee
qui insiste sur l'amélioration pour les
entreprises et la baisse du coût atteint
du pouvoir d'achat pour les foyers
l'automobile française toujours dans le
noir toutes les marques sont en recul le
mois de juin restera comme un mois
catastrophiques
après la jordanie visite éclair de
françois mitterrand en egypte la
situation au proche orient était encore
au centre des conversations barre tout
toujours maillot jaune du tour de france
c'est un autre redoute qui a remporté
l'étape d'aujourd'hui mais pas de
changement notable au classement général
mesdames messieurs bonsoir nous allons
développer ses titres dans un instant
mais c'est par une histoire que nous
ouvrons ce journal une histoire
exemplaire qui remonte à 1947 et qui
revient aujourd'hui dans l'actualité
puisque ce matin deux hommes accompagnés
d'une centaine de leurs amis se sont
rendus à l'elysée et au ministère de la
justice
37 ans après leur condamnation dans une
affaire criminelle
ils réclament toujours leur
réhabilitation il faut dire que leur
procès s'est déroulé dans des conditions
tout à fait incroyable
une affaire qui remonte à l'immédiate
après guerre et qui avait fait un bruit
énorme à cette époque c'était le procès
miss étiez nous tous deux accusés
d'avoir tué un garde-chasse
le reportage de jérôme bunny et françois
granier ce matin devant l'elysée gabriel
thiennot l'un des deux condamnés étaient
accompagnés d'une centaine de
sympathisants venus du département de
l'indre pour soutenir la demande de
réhabilitation de miss métier nous une
affaire qui remonte à 1947 mais dont on
parle encore dans la région de
châteauroux le 1er janvier 1947 on
retrouve dans un étang près de saint
michel en brenne
le corps de louis boitard garde-chasse
de monsieur legault dit propriétaire de
2800 hectares
celui ci reçoit ce meurtre comme un
affront et suit pas à pas le déroulement
de l enquête
deux jours après les policiers arrêtent
14 jeunes chasseurs qui aurait eu
affaire aux gardes chasse les deux
meurtriers seraient raymond miss 20 ans
l'un des enfants d'un métayer polonais
assez mal acceptée dans la région et
gabriel thiennot 19 ans d'une famille
nombreuse et pauvres gabriel thiennot a
été libéré en 1954 il a aujourd'hui 57
ans et vit toujours dans l'indre
accompagné d'un autre prévenu de
l'époque il a accepté de revenir à la
mairie de mézières-en-brenne là où se
sont déroulés des interrogatoires bien
particulier dès leur arrivée dans cette
salle le commissaire leur a fait
comprendre que de toute façon il en
sortirait coupable et le commissaire
tarot le commissaire de l'époque me dit
et c'est bien apple c'est bien la corse
est un apport ici je veux que ce soit un
poste de radio moi je suis comme ici à
tout de même il dit si je veux que je
sois ce soir aux radios ça sera un peu
de radio et huit jours après le poil
s'étaient transformés en postes de radio
et c'était la pj de limoges et bien la
bagarre a commencé et puis c'était un
mur à l'autre excédera et puis faire la
prière des juifs à genoux sur une règle
en fer 1 est tout nu dépendant des
heures entières fallait tenir le plus
longtemps possible quand c'est qu'on
s'écroule et on ne mettait des sourires
sur la figure pendant une semaine
aucun voisin ne s'est manifesté j'ai
trouvé à passer dans la rue et j'ai vu
les deux qui sortait de la mairie avec
une couverture sur la tête et tout ce
que j'ai vu les voisins ont entendu
quelque chose à l'époque on vient tous
les oiseaux entendait tous les bases et
entendait qu'est ce que vous voulez très
violente douleur
nous avons retrouvé un gendarme qui
avait participé aux interrogatoires
le commissaire d'aruba contrat et forcé
à signer à papier dont je ne connais pas
le contenu
résultat de ces dépositions miss et
thiennot sont condamnés à 15 ans de
travaux forcés les autres chasseurs à
des peines allant de 18 mois à deux ans
de prison bénéficiant d'une remise de
peine
miss et thiennot ont passé sept ans et
demi en détention a libéré cette année
et j'ai fait mon service militaire après
comes to town qui ne révèle aucune
coloration c'est ce qui est
incompréhensible et aujourd'hui on se
bagarre tout le temps pour obtenir
justice et puis voilà la justice va pour
moi c'est aujourd'hui quatre délégués du
comité de soutien ont été reçus au
ministère de la justice
on leur a laissé espérer une réunion
prochaine de la commission de révision
des procès
chaque année à pareille époque l'insee
qui est chargée d'étudier en profondeur
l'économie de notre pays cet institut
rend un rapport que les experts
attendent avec impatience un rapport
publié deux fois par an le dernier vient
donc de sortir et livre des
enseignements forts intéressants sur
l'évolution économique de la france il
s'agit tout à la fois d'un bilan et
d'une anticipation
c'est ainsi qu'au lycée estime qu'il y
aura deux millions et demi de demandeurs
d'emploi à la fin de cette année ce qui
est une confirmation de la tendance
observée aujourd'hui mais surtout
l'insee entre dans le détail des
changements intervenus ces derniers mois
on y apprend notamment que si les
entreprises vont plutôt mieux les
ménages français vont quant à eux un peu
moins bien
christian mary mono la rigueur touche
plus particulièrement les ménages leur
pouvoir d'achat baisse sera de près d'un
point pour la deuxième année consécutive
et cela malgré la baisse de leur épargne
deuxième mauvaise nouvelle le chômage le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi approchera
les deux millions cinq cent mille d'ici
la fin de l'année
élément nouveau après l'industrie le
commerce et les services ne crée plus
l'emploi cette politique de rigueur des
aspects positifs
tout d'abord le déficit commercial en 84
ne devrait pas dépasser 25 milliards de
francs et cela grâce à l'agroalimentaire
la vente d'avions et de matériel
militaire
ensuite la hausse des prix ne devrait
pas dépasser si selmi cette année cela
est dû notamment à la faible hausse des
salaires
enfin la situation des entreprises va
s'améliorer les investissements vont
augmenter de 12% notamment dans
l'industrie mais en retard ce qui exclut
toute effets bénéfiques sur l'emploi
le point fort c'est donc l'amélioration
de la situation financière des
entreprises ne vont pas créer d'emplois
mais seront plus compétitive exception
faite pour l'automobile et le bâtiment
tout ça ça ne va pas très bien la
politique de rigueur du jacques delors
porte donc ses fruits l'inflation va
diminuer notre balance commerciale va
s'équilibrer en principe d'ici à deux
ans le quotidien britannique le
financial times je suis d'ailleurs
positive les mesures de stabilisation
prises par le gouvernement français
mais craint que les fruits de cette
gestion ne bénéficient pas politiquement
au gouvernement de gauche
il est vrai que l'entreprise france se
portera en 84 un peu mieux qu'en 83 mais
les français eux récoltent les fruits
amers de cette rigueur
les syndicats ne manqueront pas de faire
référence à ce document de l'insee pour
exiger une amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat et salariés cette baisse sera
t-elle compensée par la réduction des
impôts des prestations sociales et du
fameux 1% sécurité sociale qui est prévu
dans quelques jours politiquement cette
annonce sera très importante
sans vouloir jouer sur les paradoxes il
est surprenant de voir qu'aujourd'hui il
y a trois fois plus de naissances
d'entreprises en france que de décès et
création l'emportent largement sur les
faillites l'aurait paradoxe car ses
créations ne permettent quand même pas
de redresser la situation de l'emploi
l'explication est simple ce sont de
façon générale que de petites et
moyennes entreprises qui voient ainsi le
jour alors que des pans entiers de
l'industrie continue de s'écrouler
une action qui n'est toutefois pas
négligeable même si elle est
insuffisante
comme l'expliquent à l'adouber ce qui ce
sont les ruines de ce que fut usinor
denain dans le nord
plus de dix mille personnes travaillent
est ici nous entendons parler bien sûr
d'une très grande entreprise dans ce
qu'elle disparaît rarement des petites
sociétés qui dans le même temps n'est-ce
discrètement parfois dans les locaux
même d'une ancienne usine désaffectée
comme ici lorsqu'on fait le bilan
les petites
créé beaucoup moins d'emplois que les
grands disparus quelques dizaines de
personnes seulement sur des milliers
retrouveront du travail pour certains ce
sera un moindre mal
il faudra se reconvertir il ya des gens
qui viennent ou de la sidérurgie a des
gens qui viennent d'ailleurs y en a pour
qui c'est le premier emploi
un immense atelier usinor abandonné par
ses centaines d'ouvriers à côté dans les
anciens bureaux une entreprise
d'électronique s'est installée mais l
emploi que quatre ou cinq personnes
quittons le cas un peu particulier des
locaux récupérer pour examiner une zone
industrielle traditionnels là encore il
se crée plus entreprises qui n'en meurt
mais le nombre d'emplois créés est loin
de représenter ceux qui ont été perdus
ces petites sociétés embauchent rarement
les premières années de leur existence
il faut attendre qu'elle ait fait des
affaires parfois elles meurent avant
bien sûr il ya des aides mais elles sont
souvent insuffisants ironise cet
industriel
oui effectivement j'ai touché des aides
sachez qu'ici nous avons investi près de
4 millions de francs et après 15 mois de
dossiers nous avons enfin toucher 100
mille francs
ça veut dire que dans leurs formateurs
les aides scénario bas cent mille francs
ça sert toujours à quelque chose
simplement on touche beaucoup moins
par rapport aux différents articles que
l'on peut trouver dans la presse et
elles sont d'autant plus très très
difficile à obtenir des êtres ou faibles
comme on vient de l'entente doubiens mal
distribué le constructeur de ces avions
ultra léger motorisé pense que
l'administration devrait tenir compte
plus du sérieux et de l'avenir d'un
produit que simplement du nombre
d'emplois créés alors il y à des
entreprises pour lesquelles les leur ai
donné l embauche au compte gouttes mais
l embauche et d'autres par contre
parfois comme celle ci située à quelques
dizaines de mètres qui disparaissent
c'est le cas par exemple de cette
entreprise d'électronique qui employait
10 personnes et qui n'a le tenu le coup
qu environ un an et demi des entreprises
qui meurt donc d'autres plus nombreuses
mais aussi plus modestes apparaissent
grâce aux aides et subventions mais de
façon globale le nombre d'emplois ainsi
créée par les petites nouvelles ne
compense pas les pertes dues aux
faillites des secteurs traditionnels
charbonnages chantiers navals sidérurgie
par exemple ainsi malgré un solde
positif de créations
le chômage a continué d'augmenter une
solution devrait être trouvée dans les
prochains jours à propos de la sphère
creusot loire c'est du moins ce
qu'annonce et pierre mauroy qui recevait
une délégation d'élus socialistes
plusieurs formules sont envisagées pour
y parvenir une information qui
intervient alors que la polémique
s'enfle encore entre le président de la
cgc pole mark kelly et le pdg de creusot
loire monsieur marc kelly reproche à ce
dernier de n'avoir pas su éviter la mise
en règlement judiciaire de l'entreprise
alors que selon monsieur martelly
il aurait pu il reprend je sais monsieur
pineau valencienne de ne s'être livrée à
une parodie de consultation des
représentants du personnel
l'industrie automobile française broie
du noir je vous le disais hier soir une
véritable catastrophe pour les marques
françaises dont le nombre
d'immatriculations a chuté d'un tiers
entre juin 83 et juin 84 une déconfiture
qui n'épargne aucune marque même si
peugeot tirent mieux que les autres son
épingle du jeu
jean-louis calméjane en six mois le
marché français de l'automobile a reculé
en moyenne de 15%
pour le mois de juin par rapport à
l'année dernière peugeot grâce au succès
de la 205 est le seul constructeur qui
limite les dégâts avec une régression de
ses ventes de 14 9%
ensuite citroën malgré la bx voit ses
ventes diminuer de 36 4%
la renault 25 qui se vend bien n'empêche
pas la régie de voir ses ventes baisser
de 37 et demi pour cent mais c'est
talbot qui trinquent le plus avec une
chute de plus de 54 % de ses ventes en
juin 84 toujours par rapport à juin 83
compte tenu de ces chiffres il paraît
déjà exclu que le marché français
dépasse cette année 1 million 800 mille
voitures neuves contre 2 millions l'an
passé
l'industrie automobile française souffre
donc de sureffectifs pour les
constructeurs les mois d'été risquent
d'être plus mauvaise encore cette
période étant traditionnellement plus
favorable aux ventes de voitures
étrangères
mais au moment où l'on fête le
centenaire de la voiture les
constructeurs français espère un arrêt
de la chute des ventes à l'automne avec
notamment le salon de l'automobile
il en va de l'avenir d'une industrie qui
emploie 400 mille personnes rien que
chez les constructeurs et les sous
traitants
le dollar a atteint un nouveau sommet
aujourd'hui à paris où il cotait 8
francs 73,25 la pause aura donc été de
courte durée
premier accusé les taux d'intérêt
américains pourtant dans la tempête le
franc résiste bien par rapport aux
autres monnaies européennes il demeure
inchangée face au deutschemark alors que
le franc suisse recule légèrement à
noter aussi qu'air france un nouveau pdg
il s'agit de monsieur marceau long qui
était jusqu'à présent à la tête d'air
inter à nouveau la tension à la
frontière du pays basque avec un
attentat la nuit dernière contre trois
réfugiés basques et espagnols
cela s'est passé à saint jean de luz où
deux hommes circulant à moto ont lancé
un engin explosif dans un bar fréquenté
par des réfugiés
bilan trois personnes blessées dont une
grièvement un attentat qui était
revendiqué tout à l'heure par le galeux
et puis de l'autre côté de la frontière
ce sont des camions français qui ont été
visés 5 et camions dynamité au nord de
burgos ces attentats n'ont pas été
revendiqués l'un des conducteurs a été
très légèrement blessé
ouverture ce matin du procès des cinq
iraniens qui avaient détourné un avion
le 6 juillet 1983 il voulait alors
attiré l'attention de l'opinion publique
sur la situation en iran des mesures de
sécurité très strictes avaient été
prises dès aujourd'hui alors que des
figures politiques de l'opposition
iranienne doivent témoigner demain à ce
procès jean marc dubois sécurité très
renforcé pour l'ouverture aujourd'hui
devant la cour d'assises de créteil du
procès des cinq iraniens
auteur d'un détournement d'avion le 6
juillet 1983
ils sont cinq très jeunes ils affirment
tous avoir plus de 20 ans mais les
médecins sont formels l'un d'entre eux à
moins de 17 ans lors de cette première
journée d'audience ils ont expliqué les
raisons et les circonstances de leur
hâte sympathisants des moudjahidine du
peuple
organisation islamique de gauche opposés
au régime de l'ayatollah khomeini il
voulait accomplir une action d'éclat
pour attirer l'attention sur la
situation en iran alors ils ont choisi
le détournement d'avion sans véritable
préparation
il avait des révolvers des vraies mais
aussi de en plastique
il n'avait jamais vu de 747 et ne savait
même pas où se trouvait la cabine de
pilotage
un détournement sans violence il n'y a
eu aucun blessé parmi les passagers
d'ailleurs ils sont seulement accusé du
détournement d'avion mais pas de prise
d'otages
demain ce sera l'aspect politique de la
faire on attend en effet les témoignages
de massoud radjavi chef des
moudjahidines du peuple et de bani sadr
ancien premier ministre de l'ayatollah
khomeini tous deux en exil à paris en
politique qu'est la motion de censure a
été rejetée à l'assemblée nationale ce
qui n'est pas une surprise elle n'a
recueilli que 159 voix alors qu'il en
fallait 246 jean marie le pen s'est
montrée particulièrement dur tout à
l'heure à l'égard de jacques chirac
alors qu'il était beaucoup plus
conciliant à l'égard de raymond barre
monsieur le pen tenait une conférence de
presse
il estime que ce qui gêne monsieur
chirac c'est que le front national
ils prennent des sièges lors des
élections quant à raymond barre il a
confirmé l'avoir rencontré à deux
reprises
selon monsieur le pen raymond barre
estime qu'il est de bonne pratique
politique de s'entretenir avec les
hommes représentatif d'un courant
politique quel qu'il soit enfin un
sondage ipsos france soir démontre une
légère amélioration de la cote de
popularité de françois mitterrand il
gagne 1% du côté des satisfaits avec 32%
tandis que les opinions négatives baisse
de 4 points passant à 47 %
pierre mauroy quant à lui reculé de deux
points avec 23% d'opinions favorables
même baisse pour les opinions
défavorables qui fasse de 54 à 52
courses le chef de l'état précisément
vient d'effectuer une visite éclair en
egypte après deux jours passés en
jordanie au caire comme à amman c'est la
situation au proche orient qui était au
centre des conversations
car sert à la visite officielle de deux
jours et demi en jordanie s'est terminée
ce matin sur un bilan somme toute
positif sur le plan des relations entre
deux pays analyse la situation régionale
qui se sont nettement rapproché resserré
affiné même entre la france et la
jordanie
la poignée de main en témoigne
d'ailleurs d'amitié chaleureuse qui
existe maintenant entre le roi hussein
le président mitterrand
un coup d'oeil d'une heure trente au
dessus du sinaï un survol du canal de
suez et le président mitterrand s'y
retrouver en début d'après midi pour
déjeuner avec le président moubarak
d'egypte qui somme toute le chef de file
des modérés zarab et qui analyse d'une
manière très pragmatique la situation
dans la région qui est actuellement
bloqué vous le savez pas élections
israéliennes les élections américaines
notamment en fait il n'y a rien d'autre
à faire que d'attendre mais on peut
mettre à profit cette période pour le
dialogue pour expliquer ce qui se passe
et surtout pour éviter que la situation
ne se détériore sur le terrain ce qu'il
faut donc éviter c'est que la situation
sur le terrain ne se dégradent président
moubarak viennent nous le dire très
clairement et c'est sans doute là la
teneur principal le sujet fondamental
des entretiens qui ont eu lieu avec le
président mitterrand aussi bien à amman
cocker aujourd'hui et on peut parler
maintenant quand on a vu la poignée de
main qui est la même à man aussi
confiante aussi amicale cocker peut
parler d'un véritable axe entre le caire
amman et paris un axe de patience
finalement en attendant que se déroulent
ces élections israéliennes d'abord et
amis
week-end peut être ensuite qui
finalement au bout du compte et en
fonction de leurs résultats
ouvrons peut-être des perspectives
pacifique au liban l'ambassade de libye
a été dynamitée cette nuit par cet homme
masqué qui en avaient auparavant fait
sortir les occupants une opération
revendiquée par un mouvement clandestin
chiite les brigades de moussa sadr et
puis le dissident soviétique andrei
sakharov serait soumis à un traitement à
base de psychotropes c'est à dire des
médicaments destinés à modifier la
personnalité c'est ce qu'affirme la
belle-fille d'andreï sakharov qui a
précisé que le prix nobel se trouvait à
l'hôpital sema show qu à gorki et qu'un
psychiatre moscovite spécialiste de
l'hypnose venait régulièrement traité
son beau père c'est le premier route que
le président du tribunal de créteil
rendra son jugement dans une affaire
dont nous vous avons souvent parlé celui
de cette femme qui souhaite avoir un
enfant de son mari décédé aujourd'hui le
procureur a refusé de prendre parti dans
cette affaire les explications de paul
lefèvre le procureur de la république de
créteil monsieur yves le sec est venu
lui-même exposer ses conclusions du
parquet
ce n'est un secret pour personne qu'il a
longuement consulté les experts du
ministère de la justice
le problème en vaut la peine il est
intéressant de constater que le
procureur n'a pas pris position
formellement ni pour ni contre la
demande de corinne mais qu'il a rappelé
au tribunal deux choses d'abord que dans
l'état actuel du droit français at-elle
enfant pourrait difficilement être
considéré comme le fils légitime de son
père je vous rappelle que corinne ne
veut pas un enfant elle veut un enfant
de son mari décédé
ensuite et c'est l'essentiel il faut
trouver dans le dossier continue de
pourrir la république
la preuve sans équivoque et sans aucun
doute qu'alain parp alex a voulu que sa
femme est un enfant de lui après sa mort
car ajouté procureur il faut éviter que
le sperme d'un mort dans l'avenir soit
utilisée par ses héritiers d'une manière
contraire à sa volonté
en somme tout retombe sur les épaules je
veux dire sur la réflexion et la sagesse
du président albert d'aucy et ses
assesseurs qui prononceront leurs
jugements le premier roues et qui
devront dire également
si leur décision pourra être exécuté
tout de suite ou s'il faudra attendre le
délai d'appel entre-temps demain au
conseil des ministres le ministre de la
santé monsieur hervé devrait
théoriquement faire le poids intérêts
flexion du gouvernement sur ce dossier
de l'insémination entre autres choses
les magistrats de créteil pourrait
préférer un bon texte mais n'en et
coûteront pas moi le ministre avec
beaucoup d'attention
un autre jugement mais en suisse cette
fois ou deux employés de l'union des
banques suisses ubs ont été condamnés à
4 et 3 ans de prison sous l'accusation
d'avoir fourni des renseignements aux
douanes françaises ils étaient entre
autres accusé de violation du secret
bancaire
hervé brusini nous rappelle les faits
violer le secret bancaire suisse
cela peut rapporter gros mais attention
cela se compte en années de prison il y
a deux ans les douaniers france y repère
deux habitués d'un poste frontière ce
sont deux professionnels des ordinateurs
de l'ue bs l'union des banques suisses
l'un des principaux établissements
financiers helvétiques janvier 83 marché
conclu contre 500 mille francs payés par
les douaniers français les deux hommes
livres 5 bandes magnétiques véritable
sésame ouvre-toi de la clientèle de
l'ubs et s peu après c'est un douanier
firme savoir décrypter une liste de cinq
métiers en français alors en suisse on
se fâche un informaticien est arrêté
mais l'autre disparaît pour de longues
vacances en martinique
le verdict de la justice suisse est
exemplaire 4 et 3 ans pour les deux
informaticiens indique le procureur
avait pourtant requis deux ans seulement
pour chacun il y a deux ans le
gouvernement inaugurait une initiative
intitulée l'opération anti été chaud
concrètement il s'agissait de prendre en
charge des adolescents habitant les
quartiers les plus sensibles des grandes
villes une façon de leur organiser des
vacances pour éviter que l'été ne
devienne pour eux l'occasion de tomber
dans ce que l'on appelle pudiquement la
petite délinquance
cette année l'opération passe la vitesse
supérieure elle était annoncée
aujourd'hui par une conférence de presse
ce sont 10 millions de francs qui seront
affectés à ce plan qui regroupe six
ministères et 14 départements
il concerne cette année cent mille
jeunes pascal guimier et pierre lepetit
sont allés visiter l'un de ses centres
l'écolo nouvelles formules comme celle
ci devrait accueillir 80 milles
adolescents cet été ici au milieu de 20
hectares de forêt viennent des jeunes de
la courneuve ou bien des grands
ensembles de seine saint denis
ils seront chaque semaine une centaine à
découvrir toute la gamme des sports des
clips un jeune qui ne fait rien sans
nuit et un jeunes qui s'ennuient risque
comme on dit de faire des bêtises à
heymans et les animateurs aussi viennent
des quartiers difficiles
certains même son ancien délinquant ces
jeunes viennent des mêmes quartiers ont
été formés en leur a donné un certain
nombre de techniques d'animation et ce
qui leur permet dans le cadre de l'été
de dany mais des groupes de de nous
aider à intervenir auprès auprès de nos
jeunes et de faire en sorte que que les
animations soir soit multipliée pour une
semaine des arbres à la place des tours
de l'herbe au lieu du macadam la
prévention à la place de la répression
le prof de gym un policier détaché par
le ministère de l'intérieur
ici les jeunes oublient leur cité
dortoir de songer à faire les courses et
tu t'ennuies chez toi la prévention ne
commence pas à 14 ans les très jeunes
eux aussi sont concernés dans ce centre
on peut amener son petit frère ou sa
petite soeur la prévention est rentable
pour tout le monde
d'abord pour ces jeunes qui ont de
vraies vacances ensuite pour l'état une
journée au centre coûte moins de 100
francs par jour à la collectivité
dépense négligeable par rapport à ce que
coûte la délinquance
une semaine en forêt c'est peu pourtant
les statistiques sont là
l'an dernier la petite délinquance a
baissé de 20% dans les banlieues
concernés par cette opération
au japon les bandits brigands proxénète
et truands de tous calibres tiennent
actuellement leur congrès national ce
n'est pas une plaisanterie même si cela
paraît être plutôt sinistre et pour
éviter tout débordement la police suit
tout cela de très près autant pour
protéger que pour surveiller les caïds
japonais michel perron costumes
traditionnels ou complet veston en
apparence un banal congrès d'hommes
d'affaires japonais et pourtant cette
réunion qui s'est déroulée hier à
tokushima était d'un genre un peu
particulier
ces braves gens sont en effet tout
simplement les membres les plus éminents
de la mafia japonaise le yamaguchi bull
plus de 13000 personnes travaillerait
donc pour ce vaste consortium qui
contrôlent l'industrie du sexe et de la
drogue dans tout le pays
on se sent policiers ont été mobilisés
pour canaliser l'honorable assistance
objet de la rencontre
intronisé le nouveau parrain
d'organisation pour éviter que la
paisible réunion ne dégénère en
règlement de compte
les autorités japonaises ont donc
fouillé minutieusement tous les
participants à part ces contrôles il ne
risque guère d'être inquiétés pour leur
réactivité leur commerce ont en effet
tous pignon sur rue et les gains qu'ils
empirent sont blanchis son circuit des
salles de jeux et des boîtes de nuit
réunis derrière ces volets ils peuvent
donc en toute impunité par faire l'art
et la manière de contourner les lois la
mort du photographe brassaï qui vient de
disparaître à nice il a été terrassé par
une crise cardiaque à l'âge de 85 ans
hamid henry miller et de picasso il
avait été le photographe du paris des
années 30 est l'un des chroniqueurs du
mouvement surréaliste
monique atlan il signait ses photos du
nom de brassaï en souvenir de sa ville
natale brassaud en roumanie à l'âge de
25 ans brassaï découvre paris où très
vite il se lie d'amitié avec picasso
matisse nu miller peu à peu il devient
un habitué de montparnasse et de sa vie
nocturne qu'il restitue à travers ses
photos en noir et blanc prises au hasard
de ses promenades de ces dérives de ses
préférences
par dessus tout brassaï mail insolite
qui se déploie surtout la nuit
méfiant et rejetant sans cesse la
sophistication et les effets qui
pourraient tenter les photographes
fascinés par leurs instruments brassaï a
choisi tout au long de son oeuvre d'être
simple témoin chroniqueur de ce paris
secret et de ces visages multiples
nouvelle victoire aux renault dans le
tour de france c'est pierre henry
menthéour qui a franchi le premier la
ligne d'arrivée de cette 13e étape
alors que son coéquipier vincent barteau
conserve toujours le maillot jaune
olivier rey et 2,6 grâce à pierre henry
mentez ou en l'équipe de cyrille guimard
a remporté aujourd'hui sa sixième
victoire depuis le départ du tour de
france
échappé avec le français domine il garde
et le danois andersen menthéour a gagné
au sprint cette 13e étape avec 7 minutes
d'avancé sur le peloton
au classement général vincent barteau
conserve le maillot jour pour ce jeune
coureur de 22 ans qui dispute son
premier tour de france
la belle aventure continue grâce à son
échappée fleuve entre béthune et
cergy-pontoise marteau et maillot jaune
du tour depuis une semaine
et au fil des jours sa popularité
augmente gens m'encouragent
formidablement
et c'est sûr qu'avec un maillot jaune
ça donne beaucoup de force d'efforts
marteau on a trouvé pour passer les
pyrénées où l'on avait pourtant prévu
son effondrement
depuis il a pris goût au maillot jaune
même s'il fait qu'il ne perdra son bout
dans les alpes prouve que le jaune me va
bien ce qui fait qu'en plus que j'ai pas
besoin de laver mes maillots renoux j'en
ai un tous les jours tous les matins et
c'est formidable
il y à un kart et demain enghien dans le
prix de quimper il y a vingt partants -1
donc 19 puisque le 6/9 milito se retire
de la course
voici les pronostics de pierrette brès
le 18 le 19 le 3 le 5 le 12 le neuf le 7
et le 15
non partant donc le 6 novelli tôt la
météo maintenant avec laurent boussier
et des tornades qui se sont abattues sur
la france ces dernières heures
oui avant de parler du temps pour demain
on va s'arrêter quelques instants sur ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui il ya eu
beaucoup d'orages sur toute la france
sur l'île de france en vendée et sur les
reliefs
on ne font que plus les caves inondées
les toitures arrachées et les vitres
brisées mais le phénomène le plus
frappant s'effacer ce matin à pamiers en
moins d'une heure dans l'ariège en moins
d'une heure la température est passée de
18 à 30 degrés les vents ont été très
violents ils ont arraché des arbres en
plein centre-ville
des vitrines ont été arrachés des
magasins ont été complètement détruits
et l'eau est rentrée un petit peu
partout à quelques kilomètres de là en
haut du pic du midi le vent a été mesuré
à près de 240 km/heure
ce qui est assez important heureusement
demain ça va beaucoup mieux demain c'est
plutôt l'accalmie regardons tout de
suite la photo qui a été prise par le
satellite meteosat en début d'après midi
la dépression qui centrait au voisinage
de l'irlande se décale lentement vers
l'est entraînant avec elle c'est énorme
masse nuageuse et pluvieuse qui dès
demain matin atteindra les côtes de
bretagne avant son arrivée il fera beau
regardons la carte du temps prévu sur
toutes les régions du sud est ce le
temps demeurera nuageux lourd et orageux
des orages qui éclatent euros dès le
début de la soirée sur l'ouest le temps
restera très nuageux avec certes
quelques éclaircies mais aussi d
ondées sur tout le reste du pays malgré
quelques nuages c'est le soleil qui
prédominera les pressions sont en baisse
les températures aussi elles sont même
en baisse importante 20 degrés sur
l'ouest 3 à 4 degrés de moins sur toute
la moitié ouest
mais jusqu'à 31 degrés en corse sur la
moitié est demain c'est le jeudi 12
juillet encore une minute de soleil en
moins puisqu'ils se lève à 5 heures 59
il se couche à 21h52 et c'est la sainte
olivier jacque séguy qui vous présentera
les dernières informations aux environs
de 23 heures 10 demain daniel bilalian
sera là à 12h45 pour antenne de midi et
jean-claude à la nique à 18h30 pour
c'est la vie bonsoir à demain 20 heures